let's change gears to the game that
allowed the steelers when combined with
cardinal seahawks to be the
last remaining unbeaten team in the nfl
at 6-0 for the first time
in 42 years when tony dungy was a rookie
on the pittsburgh steelers and led the
steelers in interception you know it's
funny
he was far more humble about it in
rehearsal than during the show
oh yeah in rehearsal i think he actually
didn't know he led the team in
receptions that year once mike tarico
told him i saw a little bit of nostalgia
come through for tony hey tony it's okay
yeah be proud be proud to think of all
those guys on that team mel
blunt donnie shell and this guy that guy
hall of famers
hell he led that team in interceptions
take it and run with it that's why i
wasn't sure if he really knew that's why
you're right in rehearsal when he
when he said it i was like maybe he
didn't know all those great i don't
think he knew he was surprised as well
but uh yeah that's a pretty damn good
one anytime you lead any statistical
category
on the steel curtain defense uh you're a
pretty damn good player
so they get it done yesterday against
the tennessee titans
and uh you know i big picture
yeah which team did we learn more about
i think i think we learned something
about both of them we did i think we
learned something about both
start with pittsburgh i i think we did i
think we learned pittsburgh first off
that defense this was like
a complete offense we had to see now i
know they let them back in the game but
i mean that was a dominant first half
to an offense that has no weakness at
all i mean derek henry ryan tannehill
they couldn't do anything in the first
half
so i think you know again that just
spotlights them to go
oh you know no matter how hot you think
your running game is
you're going to play the pittsburgh
steelers you better think you better
find some other way because you're not
just going to run the ball in pittsburgh
and i think the thing i learned more
than anything mike
was just big ben in the offense you know
i think it's it's the second week in a
row we're seeing where
you know the short passing game and the
run game they're really good at it
they use the short passing game as kind
of a de facto run game because they're
not
they're still getting better at it but
able to control the ball stay on the
field
be efficient that way i think that was
the big thing we at least i wanted to
see from pittsburgh
from that standpoint and man third downs
and some of the drives they put together
yesterday were very impressive
yeah and look it was all about stopping
the run again i spoke to tj1 after the
game and he echoed what cam hayward said
last week about the browns
when you're facing a team with a running
attack like that you have to stop the
run
and you know that takes steam out of the
play-action passing game
and also it was a point of pride for the
steelers
to to go out there especially in the
first half and keep derek henry
out of the secondary that was the goal
and it worked until it didn't i mean in
the second half
any other year titans down 27-7
they're done it's over put a fork in and
and that's what i think we learned about
the titans even in defeat
it's never over they're never going to
give up and they're built
to erase deficits and they erase that
deficit
and uh you know i it just it i think
last year the year before i mean they
were just a team where once you had them
down it was done
for the most part not yesterday not
against a great team like the steelers
so
you know i think they can they can carry
that away yep
to the extent that mike variables
looking for something that he can use to
to stoke his team in a positive
direction there's plenty there's
that's there that he could he could
point to that's negative to try to
reinforce
messages that way but the positive is
they didn't give up they didn't quit and
that will serve them well
later in the year and in the postseason
yeah no it definitely will i mean it at
least gives them the confidence to go
wait we're down by 20 we're down by 17.
well we got the drop back pass game that
can do it we don't need just to be derek
henry
balanced offense play action passes do
all those things they do not
they have a very impressive drop back
pass game we know with some of those
receivers adam humphries corey davis
back in the lineup to go with aj brown
and company yesterday
there's a lot to defend there so i do
think there is some confidence there to
be had certainly
uh you know they they they ran into a
team who i think wanted to prove a point
yesterday too
in pittsburgh i do i think pittsburgh
had this marked on their calendar a
little bit like you know
hey you know yeah everybody tennessee
they're the big bad football team cool
but uh um we're the pittsburgh steelers
and we're still a force to be reckoned
with here i think this was kind of their
coming out party
take notice of us we are for real
because
even with the game and the comeback the
titans made you know mike think about
this too before the half
the stupid interception by big ben
they're in field goal territory
i mean at half time what was it 24 to 7
it should have been 27 to 7.
and then you know of course that would
have led to 30 to 7 instead of 27 to 7.
we'll see where that goes whatever i
know that
but even the bad interception in the
fourth quarter down the middle that was
another field goal opportunity
so pittsburgh just like you said with
tennessee they'll be able to take
positives pittsburgh will be able to
take it go away from the game and go
well we should have won this game by 10
by 14 by 17 too
um i'll be excited to watch a rematch i
think both of these teams are here to
stay i wouldn't be shocked if we saw
this in the afc championship game would
not be shocking
and i think one of the things that's
happened with the steelers they fight
and scratch and claw
against teams that were clearly inferior
to them early on
but the thing is when you come out of
that game
with the win that that gives you
a little something it gives you a little
boost
it gives you a little swagger and it
builds on itself
and then you finally get a chance to
play a team that
is supposedly good in the browns yeah
although they
they found a way to redeem themselves
yesterday and you
you beat the crap out of them now you're
feeling even better about yourself see
that's the thing
teams get better and teams get worse
they never
stay the same so whatever the steelers
were the first few weeks when they were
trying to find their
sea legs they found them and they blow
out the browns they go to tennessee and
beat an unbeaten team
and and now here we go and oh oh by the
way
oh yeah baltimore baltimore's coming
here bingo
yeah at baltimore and and while we're
perusing
the remainder of the steelers schedule
yeah other than the two games against
baltimore right
and a trip to buffalo week 14. it's
fairly easy right
hey two games against the bengals
washington
jacksonville indianapolis we're not
quite sure who they are that's later in
the year
uh this steelers team with
with six wins in the bank
to start the season and 10 games left
i mean no watch out watch out 13-3
i'm looking at this schedule 13-3
isn't just reasonable 13-3
based on how they played so far this
year you could say his worst case
for the steelers based on what we've
seen so far this year well you know it's
all subject to change but here's the
thing
right mike tomlin mike tomlin is not
going to let them
look at the crap they went through last
year and i i think that they are now
reaping the benefits chris
sure of believing of holding it together
of fighting through adversity
because this year the university's not
there like it was last year
because they have a quarterback and and
i think they learned a lot about
themselves last year
this is going to cause them to stay
focused and keep taking these teams down
one after another after another and even
if they should lose at baltimore next
week which is arguably the toughest game
left for them
on the schedule even if they lose that
game they're not gonna
they're gonna they're just gonna keep
going and tomlin will will force them to
keep going
uh this this is a this is a team that is
a super bowl contender
they're gonna be there yeah no i'm not
saying they're gonna be in the super
bowl but you're there
one of them in the last few no but i'm
saying they're yeah they're down that
short list of teams where you're willing
to say right now
they could win the super bowl like
there's no you know um we're sitting
here
i have no problem saying that we're
sitting here week seven nfl season right
now
i i can tell you the pittsburgh's in
that small group of teams that you go
they can win the super bowl you know
yeah i mean you know we could sit here
and name them off right now
i don't know i mean yeah right now just
how do you feel comfortable i feel
comfortable tennessee could win a super
bowl pittsburgh can win a super bowl
kansas city and baltimore and the afc in
the nf tampa
and then within the nfc yeah i was gonna
go over there i'm gonna go tampa for
sure
no doubt about it and you know
yes seattle and new orleans i'm going to
throw them in there as well
but tampa and new orleans i'm i'm not
ready
and i'm not ready to run out of the
49ers yet either i'm not ready
kyle shanahan he's got them going but
our point is
we like what we see from pittsburgh and
they are legit and i think the big thing
is to me mike more than anything and
you know it just seems like we knew the
defense was good
they've worked out some of the kinks
where they let some teams hang around
early on in the year and all that but
it's really big
ben chase claypool deontay johnson
coming back
james connor and the offensive line have
all just come together here just
recently ever since the eagles game
three weeks ago and i think that gave me
a different feel about their team
altogether where i just started to go oh
wait all right they got a few ways they
can beat you now you know with the
defense the run game the screens the
deep passes they got a little of
everything to throw at you now and
that's where they're dangerous and uh
i'm with you i mean it sounds like
you've traded in
purple for black and yellow black and
yellow black and yellow
no oh crap bull crap i'm enjoying
no no i'm just enjoying the season and
here's the thing
with ben roethlisberger you know even
though he wasn't perfect yesterday he is
keenly aware of his legacy
at one point before the season he spoke
of an aspiration to win
super bowls multiple super bowls i mean
think about it he's pushing 40.
but there's an urgency there the team is
so much better this year and i think
what they went through last year really
has helped match the level that they're
at
right and they're just gonna keep
pushing and pushing we'll keep pushing
through what happened yesterday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports